I got a challenge for you this weekend
this will be the fourth one of the year
and this challenge is specifically
directed to the people who think they
are talented I am speaking to you today
you ready you talented person you let me
tell you what this challenges to you you
know what is the first skillset talented
people master here's what it is they
master the art of winging everything let
me explain to you why you see talented
people typically know how to wing
themselves above most people meaning
you'll go to place and let you say for
most of the guys you go in and compete
without making 40 grandeur you'll find
yourself getting to 70 80 maybe even a
hundred thousand dollars but then
talented people get to one point where
you will be exploited and it's very
embarrassing and by the way most
talented people don't like to be
embarrassed because all their lives
they've been able to you know get
themselves out of situations because of
how great they are and how good they
speak and how charming and charismatic
they are but the moment you get to a
level when you start really facing
people that know how to compete on what
it takes to really make it to the top 1%
or 0.1% they see all the leaks in your
game so let me explain to what I mean by
this you see in a world of business
there are two different types of context
you'll make here's what I mean by it
there's a types of context you'll make
that'll give you referrals that'll give
you a good sale good opportunity you'll
be given a good referral maybe you'll
make 600 bucks on a sale or $300 or $100
or $500 or $800 and it's cool it was a
good contact you made either they're
buying from you or they're introducing
to you somebody that's gonna buy from
you and Anna and then there are people
you're going to meet and make contact
with that could completely change the
face of your business change the face of
your bank account the reaction of the
banker when you go to deposit or check
because the banker looks at you and does
a double take it's one of these things
hi how are you great I'd like to make a
deposit okay no problem hi mr. Jones
it's a different look at yet you know
why here's the look the look is a look
of a person who is super prepared and
they don't wing it anymore this is what
I mean by when I say two different types
of context you seek him wing it with
every contact you meet and just kind of
treat it and put it in your account and
follow up and do all that other stuff
then you can meet a person that can
completely change you to a life your
business and that one contact requires
you to do more research
you can't wing that contact you can't
copy/paste a message and send it on
Facebook or LinkedIn and make a mistake
and accidently call somebody Tom that
was mr. Jones and mr. Jones was going to
be your biggest account and mr. Jones is
so impressed by you because you actually
research what mr. Jones does when mr.
Jones likes what mr. Jones is interested
in and what rubs mr. Jones the wrong way
and when you don't pay attention to
details like there were contacts that
are here and they have a lot more to
offer then 300 of these contacts
combined together you lose and the
reason why you're lost is because you
try to wing your way to the next level
and contacts at this level are not fools
they expect you to know what you're
doing they expect you to put that
additional energy into they expect you
to not wing yourself to the level of
doing business with them they are
insulted by your lack of research and
your lack of putting effort into it so
this is my challenge to you this week
whatever you do ask yourself am i
winging it or am I going a little bit
above and beyond am i winking it just
because I'm trying to win get with my
talent or I'm trying to really do what a
1% or 0.1% we're doing this game and
every time you catch yourself adjust and
ask what would the point 1 percent of be
doing in this same exact situation and
whatever it is adjust to that and by the
way I'd love to hear from those of you
that actually applied this to your week
and hopefully make you a permanent habit
for the rest of the year and if you
haven't watched a video how to research
a topic I'll put a link below as well
Mario let's put a link below on how to
research a topic it's a video you must
watch to know what I mean by researching
topics before you go out and wing
yourself to selling somebody else